[Music]
drex here from drexfactorpoi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and today i'm teaching you all a combo
that actually has been a really fun
thing for me to play around with
recently too before we dive in i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard and lane
mochinski thank you both so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission
so
real talk this is my second time
shooting this tutorial
um i actually shot it a day before and
got it into the editing suite and
discovered that none of the audio was
usable because apparently i had made a
mistake in how i connected my microphone
to the recorder
and i'm still a little salty about it
but i'm gonna try and not have that have
an impact on the information that i
convey to you all out there
so
take two and this is a beginner slash
intermediate combo there's a way that
you can do it more or less just as a
beginner combo and we'll get into that a
little bit later on but to get down this
combo you are going to need the
following tricks under your belt number
one waist straps and specifically if you
can do these waist straps as archer
weaves that's going to be a big help to
you
number two windmills and if you can do
these windmills as part of a four beat
fountain even better
finally c-caps in a hands-together
position
alternately you can do this as
extensions and together opposite we're
gonna get into that as i show you the
combo i'm gonna leave links to tutorials
for all of these combos down in the
description as well as up on screen in
the cards if you have to be watching on
youtube i'm going to show you the combo
at full speed then take you through it
step by step and then show it to you
again in slow motion
[Music]
all right so the whole theory behind
this combo was essentially to build up
momentum in various different ways
so um it starts off with just going into
a simple waist strap going back and
forth and you'll note the presentation
that i'm doing in this waist strap is
really closer to like an archer weave
fountain
i'm taking it down across the bottom
going both to my right as well as to my
left
this of course means that as i'm going
from left to right here because my
dominant direction of spin is clockwise
it feels kind of like an anti-spin move
and going back to the left it feels more
like an in spin move
if you want to just do this with your
hands together that also works just so
long as you're taking it down across the
bottom going both ways yeah cool so
we're going to take that to the left
to the right
to the left
and then we're going to change things up
when we go back to the right over here
namely as we go over to the right we're
going to kind of curl up our left knee
close to our right leg why are we doing
this because it's going to show that
we're winding up for something really
big and powerful and it signals to the
audience that that change is about to
happen so as we go over here to the
right we go around in that windmill and
as we come around out of it i'm going to
kind of poke my right hand poi
underneath my left hand poi
almost like i'm doing a little bit of a
pendulum here
and it is going to swing around over to
my right hand side then please note um
i'm coming from having that left knee up
to opening back up into like more of a
solid stance
with my weight evenly distributed
between my two legs as i do so so all
together then that turns into i go left
i go right
i go left
i wind up to the right
go around and hit my
right hand poi out to my left hand swing
it around to my right and this is where
things change up so then i've got my
right hand pull over to my right hand
side here i'm going to bring up both
hands into a
c-cap or a set of c-caps with my hands
together my poi in opposites as i go up
i'm bringing up my left knee with my two
poi and i'm kind of arching my back a
little bit uh as as this happens boom as
i come back down
now if you don't have your c caps down
you can instead do this as a pair of
extensions that is they go around
in much the same way you don't even have
to pick up your your uh your left
knee you just take them around like so
it makes no difference for what the next
move is so after you've done that c-cap
or extension you kind of do a little
splat where the poi kind of poke out to
either side of like your right hand poi
is going to go forwards your left hand
poi is going to go behind you
if you're doing the c cap it means that
you're taking this moment when they come
down and you're just kind of letting
them
reach out to either side if you are
doing
your
extensions it just means that you kind
of end it with a little bit of a
pendulum as
you get to that position where normally
your right hand point would be going
reverse which is a good thing to note
here that as you're doing that pair of
extensions it is with your right hand
poi feeling like it's going reverse and
your left hand poi feeling like it's
going forwards as they go around and
then kind of stalling out yeah now from
here you're going to start trying to
like almost stock towards the audience
where you're going to step with your
right foot
down stage left as the right hand poi
comes around in front and then you're
going to switch around to stepping down
stage right with your
left foot as your left hand poi comes in
front and from here
you're going to switch things up just a
little bit again namely as that left
hand pulley is swinging down and around
you're going to give it just a little
bit of momentum to bring it up and
around yeah
it carries your entire body around with
it
and
you wind up bringing both of your poi
down over to stage right here so all
together the tail end looks like this we
start stalking towards the camera
like so
left takes us around
and we stop with both poi down over to
your right hand side or over to stage
right so the entire combo from the top
looks like this
we do
our weave over to the left
our weave over to the right
move over to the left
wind up
go around that windmill stop the poi
come up in our caps or extensions we
start walking down towards the camera
let's the left hand
carry us around and stop over here at
stage right yeah all right let's do that
again in slow motion
[Music]
all right hopefully that was worth a
second pass yes i'm still a little salty
all right
uh anywho
uh one of the reasons that i stopped
doing these combo tutorials last year
was that i got to a point where it felt
like um
you know
i do these videos in order to give
people out there things to work with and
as people stop posting their own
versions of these combos it kind of felt
like i was just speaking out into the
void so if you would do me the honor if
you learn this combo please please
please post video of it
to the internet whether it be instagram
facebook youtube what have you i am
drexfactor on all these different
platforms please tag me so i can see
that the work that i'm doing is having
an impact on other people it really
means the world to me um and even a
bigger bonus if you're on instagram and
you throw a video of this combo up in
your stories tag me i will repost you to
my own stories so all my followers can
see your hard work and of course if you
got anything out of this video please
make sure to like comment share and
subscribe both to help other people find
it as well as to keep the conversation
going and to help my channel grow thanks
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these
wonderful people right here these are my
flow patrons on patreon and they along
with the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
do you like my videos do you like float
sessions do you like combo tutorials do
you like reviews and vlogs well i'm on a
mission to help bring poi spinning and
flow arts to the wider world and i need
help in doing so so please help me out
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi and signing up
you can do that either at the link down
in the description or the card that just
popped up if you are watching on youtube
there you can find a variety of
different awards available to my patreon
subscribers so i hope one of them
inspires you to sign up please and thank
you the one not bad part about having to
reshoot all of this is that the weather
has actually been delightful in dc for
the first time in
uh it's 60 degrees out today so it is
actually not unpleasant to be outside
and re-recording these videos hallelujah
so i hope you all have a great weekend
thanks so much for watching i'm going to
include a
link to a playlist of other combo
tutorials that i've done down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on youtube
make sure to get out and flow this
weekend and i'll see you with a new
video on monday
peace